cinnamon and it's been two years it's so
fun to be back it's amazing seeing
everybody
it's amazing to still feel like such so
part of the family and so you know just
blessed to be here
the Hadi Prince Lou's back making her
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show return
for the first time since giving birth to
her two daughters it honestly felt like
I've never left this building and when I
came in someone told me they were like
Oh welcome home and I was honestly so
touched by that it made me emotional I
was like I do feel home I feel like I've
never loved a et caught up with the 30
year old model backstage before she
strutted her stuff on the catwalk and
she dished on getting back in angel
shape I worked out a lot I I was really
focused on building my body back just
after kids you almost feel stronger you
want to do it more you want to prove
more I did it really slowly
I waited for months after I had Gio and
slowly start working out again just was
healthy I was breastfeeding which helped
a lot and I'm just so proud of today and
where I am and how I feel and that I
have two girls at home I mean it's crazy
I could cry there is a few mothers in
the show and it's so fun we see did you
see each other we're like we know what
you went through girl you know there was
like a little a little unspoken bond
between us all it's nice to to feel like
you're you're inspiring other girls too
while the hadi might be inspiring other
new mamas her hubby Adam Levine keeps
her motivated he is a special person
that guy he keeps me going to cuz he's
such a workout junkie he's so full of
energy he hyped me up you know sometimes
I'm like ah I can't do this anymore it's
like you can
he's the bass and the maroon 5 frontman
will be front-row Center for her big
return to the show you would think that
it would make me more nervous but it
actually excites me more because I love
seeing him there
he says he's like my number-one
cheerleader and I almost feel like I'll
be better with him there he's so fun
he's like I'm so excited just to be
there to watch and not be like
performing or not you know so it's my
moment and he's there to see my
[Music]